keep government open we intent we have
to do those imminently uh more
intimately even to address the full
Obama agenda of building back better
with and I love to say building back
better she meant Biden but she said
Obama and you know often this is now
coming up all the time because anyone
with half a brain realizes that Biden is
not in charge right he's just not he's
the figurehead that they put out there
to read often poorly off the
teleprompter and Mumble and stumble
through anything that he's doing strange
I remember those eight years when Obama
was President did he ever say building
back better I don't think so but he did
once say I'm sure many of you have seen
the interview where he said he would
love to have a third term he knows he
can't have a third term so he'd love to
just pull the strings from behind so
every now and again they tell you
exactly what they're doing